[Musique]
amoureux des corails bonjour bonjour je
vois beaucoup lâché maçonnique asile et
n vous avez 65 ans vous êtes le maire
10,3 il est depuis 1989 ce qui fera en
2020 31 ans que vous êtes à la tête de
la commune et vous êtes candidat à votre
succession
vous allez conduire la liste trois ilets
nouvelle dynamique
qu'est ce qui vous motive encore ce qui
motive c'est que je fais de la politique
effectivement depuis un certain nombre
d'années et que pour domaine aussi
combattre et âme à combattre tout ce qui
se passe dans notre pays il faut être un
élu un élu mais a dit rose hill et
permettra effectivement de participer
aux élections
une élection capitale comme la ctm en
2020 donc ça c'est une première chose
deuxième chose j'ai fait effectivement
ne va simplement de du groupe
la majorité municipale il supposait la
question s'il y avait des candidats qui
pourraient effectivement prendre la
suite
au contraire nous dit c'est arnaud tu
restes là et parce que nous ne sommes
pas encore prêts pour pouvoir prendre la
suite
après trente ans de mandature il n'y a
pas de relève la relève se ce n'est pas
au maire de créer la relève il faut que
des jeunes des moins jeunes puissent
avoir la capacité de se libérer de se
rendre disponible pour se mettre à la
disposition d'une population aujourd'hui
ça n'a rien à voir avec mes premières
années le meilleur des trois îles et
aujourd'hui il faut de la disponibilité
il faut des perspectives de
développement il faut une maîtrise de la
situation financière et à sept nombre de
choses que les élus au sein du conseil
municipal sont en phase ii
en fait de d'appréhender de façon à
permettre à 3 il est toujours d'évoluer
dans le sens que nous l'avons fait
depuis 1989
d'accord vous avez utile lui vous aviez
34 35 ans à tafer oui là ça fait 30 ans
que vous êtes allah allah aux manettes
vous vous dites que qu'il faut que vous
n'arrivez pas à impulser une relève à
trouver quelques que vous pourriez forme
et non mais c'est comme ça bien sûr dans
le sein du conseil municipal des jeunes
des personnes des personnalités qui se
forment mais je vous dis je le répète un
aujourd'hui la disponibilité est
primordial 20 certes je suis un retraité
aujourd'hui de la fonction bancaire
donc je sens c'est quelque chose pour
mettre sacrifier quelques fois par
rapport à mon à mon emploi donc il faut
aujourd'hui une commune comme 3 il est
disons deux jumelles habitants mais en
qu'il ya à peu près de 12000 personnes
avec des entreprises qui fonctionnent
avec des perspectives d'avenir avec le
développement qui se réalise
particulièrement dans le domaine
économique il faut à ce moment là une
certaine disponibilité et une certaine
disant appréhension de la chose publique
l'isie je confirme ce n'est pas si quand
on fait de la politique on ne fait pas
de la politique pour occuper une place
on fait de la politique pour pouvoir
permettre effectivement à son pays
d'évoluer et mon pays c'est la
martinique mon pays ma ville silice
trois îles et je vis ou 3 il est ce une
neo 3 il est et je travaille pauli 3 il
est comme gelée toujours fait comme je
lé fais pour l'association sportive
éveil des trois îles et pendant plus
d'une dizaine d'années
c'est cette somme en leitmotiv c'est
tout cela qui me motive pour aussi
continuer mais aussi par rapport à ceux
qui se présentent aux trois ilets et je
ne peux pas laisser ma commune à commune
des trois ilets homage gens qui ne
veulent pas de logements sociaux aux
mains de gens qui ne veulent pas de
centres d'activités multi activités
comme le 10 sport
qui voulaient bloquer ce hall des sports
en demandant à un administré de porter
plainte pour pouvoir retarder le dossier
à ce genre de personnage qui se présente
dans une ville où kiala qui a pris parce
que comme je lui ai dit il faut un fou
un sens à la politique
la ville des trois ilets comme beaucoup
de communes ont décidé de mettre à la
disposition des sociétés des bailleurs
sociaux du terrain pour permette
effectivement la construction de
logements quand on vient dans un conseil
municipal et voûte est contre et contre
la mise à disposition de terrains ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on est
content qu'on est contre le logement
social parce que je dis on ne sait même
pas comment est calculée au loyer
voilà ce que je dis allez cela d'autant
plus que je suis candidat alors est
certain qu'ils disent à leur propre
succession ne lancez pas ma propre
succession
je suis candidat pour permettre
effectivement 3 il est de continuer à
évoluer il reste très peu de temps vous
vous êtes le/la avance nous avons a
lancé avec le pf une deuxième
manifestation d'intérêt et le début du
mois de janvier nous allons avec une
commission composée d'élus mais aussi de
personnalités attribué au proposé au
conseil municipal l'attribution d'un
nouveau de nouveaux projets alors
beaucoup d'administrés ce sera la
dernière question disent que la
population est fracturée chez vous et
que les personnes ne se mélangent pas
que deux côtés il est allé blanc de
l'autre côté il ya des noirs
en trente ans la ville est ce que vous
avez constaté cela non ce c'est tout à
fait faux donc aussi municipal une
population j'ai des élus qui sont une
population métropolitaine
je rencontre les métropolitains il y a
dans tout pays où il ya une population
qui n'est pas autochtone il y as on a
l'impression et la sensation que cela se
passe mais lee les gens se parlent au
niveau des écoles au niveau de la
municipalité au niveau des associations
sportives et culturelles nous avons de
plus en plus une intégration de cette
population qui forment pourtant de trois
îles et c'est vrai aux arts nous
redécouvrir je vous remercie je vois
bien sinon vos invités